That's a bit of a pain. Here is how you convince
the Java compiler to do it anyway. This is a very strange
syntax, whose origins are somewhere in the mist of time of
programming languages and we won't dwell on that. But here is what
you need to do. This value here, is of type double.
Now we don't want it to be in double. We want it
to be in integer. And then you have to put the
name of the type that you want and, put parentheses around it.
And put it before the expression you want to
convert. What now happens is, this expression here is
computed. The fractional part is discarded. The integer
part, is moved over here. This operation is called
a cast. That's a curious name, are we
casting out a fishing rod? Is it cast around
a broken a foot? The cast of characters in a play? Well I guess it's mostly like
the latter, becaues we have this value here.
That actually is a, fractional number and we want to
cast it, not as the hero in the play
but as an integer. Whatever, that's just what it's
called. Every once in a while, you need
to do this. You have, something that's not of
the type that you want, you want to change its
type and, the cast notation does that for us.